Justin now you explored different
musical dramas with your music and now
the Rolling Stones they asked you you
just gone solo is this right yes Rolling
Stone said we love Justin Timberlake
come be part of our world naturally yeah
it was a charity event that you get a
call from the I'll pick this name up
after I drop it Mick Jagger and and he
says we want you to come and play the
event and and so I said sure is in
Toronto and you would think I mean
Canadians are historically peaceful a
peaceful people and I show up to the
show I look at the bill and it's the
Rolling Stones and ac/dc and the guess
who and you get the picture and like
somewhere in there me I just you know it
was a bit of a blur but I just remember
saying to the band before we went on
stage I don't think this is gonna go
well and and but little did I know I had
no idea how bad who's going to go
because we came on stage and all of a
sudden from the first two rows of
probably I think this festival in one
day house half a million people
Wow so that was crazy but all of a
sudden bottles of urine were were then
thrown on the stage it wasn't always
good times for me he got that's a lot of
piss off tonight
just the first two railroads yeah all of
these questions I had going through my
brain to at least remember lyrics that I
actually wrote to the first song that
I'm playing so yeah it was
I still have unanswered questions but I
saw a lot of trauma yeah
and after the first song the host of the
festival comes out he's like it sounds
like none I'm staying out here we're
doing this and so then the plastic
contained urine continued to write
Addison I was having this like I was
like the first song that was at the mic
and I was like you know like moving
around and singing at the same time and
it's kind of impressive myself and then
the second song was senorita I feel for
you that's making this story easier to
tell and and I play a Rhodes electric
piano on that song so then all of a
sudden I'm thinking myself oh no I'm a
mobile like so it was this
and then after that song either one of
two things happened either they ran out
of nerve because they knew that was
going to stay there or they ran out of
urine so kids be tenacious
[Applause]
[Music]
you